Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab,
the podcast podcast. And in
this podcast I have learned, no,
how would you describe
this one? My sense is that
you walk into a wild place and you hear
the wind and the trees and you hear
these trips and sounds and calls
and they're just part of the,
they're part of the
wild. They're wild life.
But there's now a group of scientists
who listen much more closely and who are
reducing wildlife to wild
talk. It's, it's a, yeah,
there are words in there.
When you find the words as the people
we will meet do in these stories,
you end up not just understanding,
but actually entering that
wild space in a very cool way.
So we're going to tell you two
tales here, two different places.
The first a jungle and the
second a prairie right.
Jungle gets it started and then the
prairie and later, uh, this is a story,
this first one that we heard
about. Yeah. Yeah. I am from Ari.
I'm Ra Daniel Shapiro. I'm a
public radio producer in Boston.
The Ra recently met a guy, I think a
German. Yes. He's Swiss. No. Okay. Yeah.
His name is Klaus Zuber,
Buhler close and he's a professor of
psychology at University of Saint Andrews,
which is in Scotland. And where
does this story actually take place?
Because where's the
jungle? Yeah, well I, I'm,
I maybe the best place to start is to
kind of describe the scene where we are,
which is in the Thai forest forest,
which is in the Ivory Coast in Africa.
So it's not in Thailand. No, it's
not. It's t a I, he a I. Okay. Yeah.
And Klaus describes the jungle
as this thick sensory world.
Very dark, very moist
and very, very green.
And you can't really see
for more than 15 to 20 feet.
And I mean sometimes you feel
like you walk through, you know,
the big cathedral of dark trees and
you don't see very much because all the
animals obviously very
shy and runaway Emmy.
Is it still a no, it's, it is,
it is very, very noisy.
It's just this kind of sonic fails all
these insects and birds who bat sea
mammals.
It's almost as if they
compete for acoustic space.
So it is very, very loud. I mean,
th th the main sensation you have in
the beginning really is that you're,
you're just completely lost.
So it's 1991 all right. And B
figured he had to start somewhere.
So he focuses attention on a kind
of monkey, very beautiful monkey,
a thing called the Diana monkey. This
mix of black, white and sort of reddish.
Diana monkeys live up in the tree tops,
which can be as high as a
hundred feet off the ground. Wow.
They eat fruits and they eat
insects and they're chattering.
Hello. Good coffin. Any of
calls, which to him,
of course, you know, as a newcomer
to the forest was all just noise.
There's a little bit, I imagine like
a child trying to learn a language,
which initially most just sound like a
stream of sounds that you can't really
understand. And then you know
what? So what did he do? Well,
he started provoking the monkeys into
making different kinds of noises.
For instance, he'd walk out into the
forest with a boombox speaker and play
[inaudible]
it sound of the Diana monkeys
most feared Predator. The leper.
He would just play the
sound into the trees. Yep.
Well all of a sudden suddenly he
started leaping around the branches.
You all who's hopping around motion
and they make this one particular call.
Ah, you these very loud
alarm calls. Yes ma'am.
Ah,
meaning what? Yeah.
Are they just saying like run or is
it something more specific? Well,
here's where it gets a little
bit more interesting. Next step.
He brought that same cassette player
out, pointed as the trees hit, play,
all that. Yep. But this time he plays
the shrieks or for Crown Eagle
Eagles eat monkeys. Yeah,
they do tack from a bowl. I've heard
about them. They're very scary.
They come flying in with
their talons. Are there
beaks and they hit you in the head sharply
and kill you instantly and then you
fall to the ground. Yeah. And so what
are the monkeys do when they hear this?
They make
ah,
that sound. Same One. Well,
that's what he thought.
But when he went back to the lab and
started looking at the sounds on the
computer comparing one to the other Eagle,
Huh? A Leopard Eagle,
a leper, he realized
woo
that they're actually slightly different
in the acoustic details of the calls.
And it's something that is very
difficult to hear when you're,
you really only see it in the spectrogram,
which is kind of a visual representation
of dis calls. This is on the computer.
Yeah.
But interestingly once you've seen that
and once you know what to pay attention
to, you go out into the forest and
suddenly you do hear these differences,
which you hadn't heard before.
Mm.
So you're saying when they hear, oh call
leopard coming, they go up the tree.
But when they hear eagle coming, they
run down the tree. Exactly. Exactly.
So it's really kind of like, oh
word. They, they like a word. No,
that's kind of amazing.
Let's pull up for a second,
cause this guy actually
got us thinking honestly,
how much language actually is out
there in the wild. What do we know?
What's the state of [inaudible] state
of what we know right
now. And that question,
let us out of the forest
just for a second.
And to a place in a creature we just
didn't think would be a part of this
conversation at all. Um, that creature is
the [inaudible] prairie dog woo.
Reverie dogs. So here's the thing.
Prairie dogs are these
little rodent like animals.
They live under the ground in burrows
and when their community is invaded,
they, you know, pop out of the
brewery, right? And they do, Oh,
here comes the whatever
sounds kind of like
g, G, G, G, g.
G. G. G.
So we spoke with this guy. Um,
my name is constable Chekhov,
professor emeritus at northern Arizona
University who spent a whole lot of time
sitting out in the colonies
according prairie dog calls.
And he now believes that these simple
little rodents are like nature's
wordsmith. Well, the thing is that
initially I recorded, for instance,
he began by telling us that the prairie
dogs have different kinds of cheese for
different kinds of predators.
For example, humans,
coyotes and docks, right?
Is this the kind of thing that we would
actually be able to hear the difference
between the calls? I'm guessing
that you could hear the difference.
You want to try it? Chat? Yeah. Sorry.
Could you just play those samples?
All right. So here, here's one.
Yes sir.
This is it. Another one.
Okay.
All right. Hey, here we go. This is it.
Third,
those represent different
predators. Yup. I don't,
I can't tell the difference. Can you,
I mean, do you know what they are?
My guess is human dog.
Coyote Khan was right.
Columbus ride. Wow. Well,
naturally we wondered
how, how'd he do that?
He told us that at first
just like you and I,
he couldn't figure out how to
distinguish between these sounds,
but he took the sound back to the lab
where we had a machine that allowed us to
measure a series of, uh, frequency
and time elements in the call.
And what this computer does is it takes
the sound that the prairie dogs make and
it essentially looks inside for the
ingredients inside the sound. Yeah.
Like, uh, well it's Kinda hard to hear
with the Chirp because it's just hard.
So let, let me demonstrate
crudely with this other sound.
I plucked this at random from my library.
So this is kind of like a buzz. Okay.
Okay. Let me just loop it
so we can hear it better.
So here you've got this buzz, which is
sounds to us like a solid piece of noise,
but getting the cue and
take away all the highs.
So now you've got just the base. Yep.
Now you'll notice that if you add
the highest back in real slowly,
these little hidden overtones
will pop out like a, here's one.
Yep. There's another
third, fourth.
So in other words,
this sound is filled with a little
ghost notes that we can't hear.
And certainly the same
is true of this sound.
Sure.
Except in the case of the prairie dogs,
it seems their ears are tuned to hear
all the different sounds within the
church.
Probably sounds to them like this whole
layer cake of tones and calms computer.
Notice the noise they made when a
human walked through their village was
different in tone from
the noise they made.
When a coyote walked through
their village, it was,
it was consistently different, but there
was a problem when he zoomed in on the,
Oh, here come the human
calls, you look here,
and he looked at them really closely.
He saw that from one
human call to the next.
There was a lot of subtle variation, much,
much more than I would expect and
that's when it hit him. What if,
what if, what if?
What if they could be describing
the individual humans? Oh,
now at that time,
no one suspected that this might even
be a possibility, but I thought, well,
let's try it and see what happens.
So Khan recruited for humans and
he had them dress exactly the same.
Same boots, same blue
jeans, same sunglasses,
everything the same except
the color of their shirts.
We had a person in a blue tee
shirt person in green tee shirt,
person in a yellow shirt
person in a gray shirt.
Then he asked each of them to walk
through the prairie dog village one by one
sprayer downs made their chips.
And when we analyze the results,
there were significant differences.
Like what kind they essentially
clustered around the colors.
Does that mean you think you can hear
them saying, here comes the human in blue,
right? Versus here comes the human
in yellow, right? Really? Oh,
I was astounded. I was astounded. I was
like, oh, wait a second. These humans,
they're not just different
in their shirt colors there.
They're different than all kinds of
ways. Some of the humans were taller,
some of the humans were shorter.
So we went back reanalyzed the chirps
looked a little more closely and he
realized he could tease out to the prairie
dogs were also commenting about the,
uh, general size of the human.
Essentially. They were saying,
here comes the tall human in the blue
versus here comes the short human in the
yellow. Wow. And then he made another
leap and it was just, you know,
since he was on a roll, um,
off the wall idea at that time,
he went back into the prairie dog field
and he built two large wooden boxes
sitting on stilts, a good distance
from each other, 150 feet.
And we strung wires
between the two towers.
His team then made cardboard
cutouts of three different shapes,
a circle, a square and a triangle. And
then they ran them out along the wire,
kind of like laundry fluttering
above you in the breeze.
Each shape would emerge from one of
the tower blinds and fly something like
about three feet over the
prairie dog town. Literally,
you would just kind of go and out would
come a triangle or a circle or square.
Correct.
And what we found was that the prairie
dogs could tell the triangle from the
circle very easily,
but they could not seem to tell the
difference between a square in a circle.
Huh? Why not? Well,
my guess is that triangles
kind of look like Cox,
mm.
Circles and squares kind of
look like terrestrial predators.
Nonetheless.
What you've got here is a little Roden
with the remarkably big vocabulary,
including the probably not limited to
short fat, skinny, tall, blue, green,
yellow, gray, coyote, human hoc
triangle. Enter a square, Yay.
Not Bad is the next step that you're
going to perform a scene from the winter's
tale and see whether the Perry
lugs laugh at the right moments.
What do you do next? Well,
we just are scratching the
surface of looking at this.
For example, prairie
dogs have a lot of calls,
which we call social chatters.
One prairie dog will be feeding and
suddenly lift up its head and go,
chitter chatter, Chitter,
Chitter, and another prairie dog.
Somewhere across the colony will lift
up its head and go, chatter, chatter,
Chitter, chitter. But what does it
mean? We have no way of getting at it.
It could be just simply chatter,
tutor, tutor, or it could be,
do you know where Sam was last night?
Now here's an interesting
question. I mean,
if a French couple was sitting next to
me on the subway and they was saying,
do you know where Sam was last night
in French? If I don't speak French,
I'm outside of that conversation.
But a lot of people do speak French
and they can listen to French people
talking. The questions then rays.
If you live in the forest and you speak
chimp or you speak eagle or you speak
snake,
would you ever be able to overhear or
learn something from a neighborly species?
In other words,
is there an equivalent of listening to
the other person talking French in the
wild? Hmm, good question. And that brings
us back to Klaus. You remember class?
The monkey guy? Yeah, the monkey guy.
Well, Klaus was wondering the same thing,
and that's a Ari Daniel Shapiro
again, who introduced us to class.
So take those alarm calls, for instance.
He wanted to know whether different
species of monkeys could understand each
other. So, um,
and luckily for class there's like at
least 10 different primate species living
inside that Thai forest.
So there's one Calibus monkey two
[inaudible] three chimpanzees,
four oligos Holbein six, Heidi knows
monkeys, seven mangabey species,
Prosimians temples, monkey, and then
the Diana's 10. Yeah. So it's very,
they rich prime at foreigner.
So Klaus's question was,
could Diana monkeys understand the alarm
calls of another one of these monkeys?
The Campbell's monkey. Oh, could they
go across monkey lines so to speak?
Exactly. So he used that
same setup from before,
the speaker thing where he
plays the, into the trees. Yeah.
Any played the eagle and leopard
alarm calls from the Campbell's money
keys to the Diana's to
see if they'd react.
And what we found thorough to our great
surprise was that the diner monkeys,
they understand it really,
really. Yep. Picked it very,
very seriously and
respond to very strongly.
So a Dianna monkey hearing a Campbell's
eagle alarm call will respond as though
there were an eagle and we'll respond to
the leopard alarm call as though there
were a leopard and vice versa.
And it doesn't stop there.
Klaus started playing the monkey
calls to birds, the truss hornbills,
yellow casked hornbills. It turns out
that they understand it. The birds,
these hornbills are capable
of discriminating these
different monkey alarm
calls. Wow. So it's a pretty
substantial Webb species,
basically eavesdropping on, on each
other's calls in these forests.
But Klaus himself, he was still
on the outside of it all. It is,
um, general sense of perhaps
not really belonging there.
But then he told me about
this one day I was uh,
working in the forest.
He had gone out for the day and he'd
gone out alone and it was very far away
from camp and it was in the late
afternoon and he realized that he should
probably be heading back to camp because
I still had to walk for a, you know,
something like 50, 20 kilometers to back
to camp. And he was walking past it,
a kind of valley and then [inaudible]
on the other side of the valley.
Got It.
A monkey group giving light, put alarm
calls, which doesn't happen that often.
It was the first time that
he wasn't actively listening,
but he heard these monkeys make
this call and recognized it.
It was absolutely striking and he was
actually quite excited by this because I
was suddenly able to understand what
the monkeys trying to say so to speak.
Those monkeys had picked up a Lebron Ah,
right beneath that sound there. The
leopard would be right, but you know,
those monkeys were way across the valley.
So I didn't really think that
more children walked on, perhaps,
you know, half, half a
mile further down the road.
And the next group of Diana monkeys,
I
still across the valley,
okay.
Start giving leopard alarm codes as
well. And he kind of took notice of that
and then it happened a third
time, a few minutes later.
What became clear to me very
rapidly is that elaborate was
tracking him. Of course I couldn't
see it because he was, you know,
dense for us. But I assume that, uh,
the, the lipid saw me of course, that,
you know, it's just one of these
moments where you're, you know,
you're totally alone, um,
far, far away from Cam.
What does he do?
He, he kept walking. It happened
at fourth group called Leopard,
fifth group called Leopard.
And then the group stopped calling.
Yeah.
The only thing I could think of is to
pick up, um, you know, a large branch.
It shouldn't laugh. That's
as terrifying. Klaus,
would that stick have
done anything for you?
Uh, I, I doubt I really would have been
able to do very much with the steak.
But as he standing there
sticking hand, he realizes
he's just entered the forest.
He's become, do you 11th primate,
the 11th primate because there are those
10 other species of primate. And now
me,
suddenly I shifted from being the
objective observer to being a,
you know, sort of part of
the whole crowd in there.
Even though, you know,
we're separated by 20,
30 millions of years of
evolutionary history, you know,
these humble creatures, um, you know,
were able to teach me
something about, you know,
what was going on in the forest. And I
mean, of course it wasn't intentional.
They weren't trying to inform me
or anything like that, but, um,
it was a, a very emotional experience.
So what happened? I mean, obviously he
didn't get eaten. What happened? Well,
he, he made it back to camp and he's
not sure what happened to the leopard.
The Leopard must've slinked
off into the forest in the end.
Another story to tell each other
over beers in the evening, I suppose.
Yeah, yeah.
Ah,
thanks for that story too. Ari,
Daniel Shapiro, our correspondent,
and also thanks to um, Klaus
Zuber, Bueller and cons.
Labatt Ukaf I'm Jad Abumrad I'm
Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.